Fingertip shopping will be one of the many homemakers' conveniences.
This video console will be channeled into the store of her choice.
There, a camera will scan a display of wares, which she will select by push button.
Another part of this console is a household monitor screen,...
...which maintains a watch on critical areas in the house, swimming pool or yard.
What the wife selects on her console will be paid for by the husband at his counterpart console.
All bills and transactions will be carried out electronically.
A central bank computer will debit the family's account the amount of purchases...
...and credit the department store, for example,...
...informing the family's home computer at the same time.
Father, at the touch of a button, receives an instantaneous printed copy of his budget,...
...the amount of taxes he owes, the payments left on the car and so forth.
All documents and household records are available on the video screen for immediate reference.
Also at his disposal is an electronic correspondence machine, or home post office,...
...which allows for instant written communication between individuals anywhere in the world.
To maintain these and hundreds of complex electronic circuits,...
...a monitor checks all circuits every few seconds...
...and serves a backup circuit if and when trouble develops...
...and alerts the communal service agency for replacement.